It's so funny to see you
(Chris laughs)
on, like, set.
I know, right?
Usually we're in my house.
I'm in my sweatpants, and-
That's right.
We talk about all things flowers.
That's right, that's right.
I want you to show us some unique ways
to display everyday, store-bought flowers, in your home.
Like, take us through flowers that are affordable.
All right, great, so you can go to your grocery store,
go to your bodega, your corner store.
You can either get one of those mixed arrangements
with lots of different flowers in a bouquet,
or you can just get a single set of flowers
like these or like these,
so you can just get a single set.
So, what I like to do is get a whole bunch,
bring 'em home, and totally disarrange them
and rearrange them.
Mm-hm.
So why don't we start with
a kitchen arrangement?
Okay.
So in the kitchen, who has counter space in the kitchen?
Nobody, so what do we do?
We elevate.
So I love this vase.
It's basically just a tube,
and you can hang it from the little lock
on your kitchen window.
I've never known about these.
And now that I know about them,
I never wanna live without them.
Right?
So what's next?
Take us through our next step.
So next, the bathroom.
It's the room I think in the house
that does the most work for us
and gets the least credit for us, right?
So let's brighten it up.
Mm-hm.
So, here we have like some sort of
standard bathroom vanity,
and I would wanna put some flowers on that vanity.
So for this, my secret weapon is a pin frog.
So this is-
Again, Christopher, I've never seen one of these,
and they've changed my life as well.
Teach us what the frog is.
Okay, so you'll take a flower.
You'll, as always, you make a fresh cut
before you actually put it in water or anything.
And we'll show you first,
out of the container what you do.
You really just, stick it in.
And it just stays up like that.
And mine-
So that's what it looks like.
So now we can actually do a couple
in the actual container.
So in this container, there is a pin frog in it.
So I'm just going to pop it in.
And so although this has a wide rim,
the flower stays perfectly upright.
So you can create some architecture.
You just put it right on your vanity.
You could do one, two, three, 20,
whatever you feel like.
Oh, also in your bathroom,
you showed me and taught me that I could
put some eucalyptus leaves in my shower.
Yeah, so this is basically the arrangement
that would go in a cylindrical container,
flipped upside down.
And you just tie it to your shower head,
and as all that steam is coming down,
it's just creating this incredible fragrance for you.
See, I wouldn't think to hang flowers upside down.
I would only do that if I was drying it.
But you sort of expand my mind
to things I wouldn't have thought of.
Okay, number three, what's our last tip?
Number three, okay, well I'm very clumsy.
I'm always breaking flowers,
or I'm getting them from a grocery store.
I'm in a rush, and half the flowers
are broken when I buy them.
So what I do is, snap the head off.
Here's an example.
Just snap the head off, the flower.
Cut it maybe a centimeter or an inch,
or something like that.
And just put it in a bowl of water.
So here we have some already snapped.
I, Christopher, I have never got an arrangement,
whether it's from a fancy florist or a bodega,
and not had the broken flowers.
Oh my god, every single time.
Every single time, and it always depressed me.
Right?
But now I feel like
I have this whole new vessel and opportunity.
Yeah.
And I would never have thought
to do floating flowers with that.
Right, you buy a $10 bouquet of flowers,
or a bunch of flowers, you know,
three of them are snapped off and you think,
oh, I just wasted my money.
You didn't waste your money.
Just throw 'em in a bowl.
I feel like I'm in a spa.
(Chris laughs)
And if you put this on your side table
or your coffee table,
which you're always looking down on anyway,
it's the perfect vantage point.
Well, the innovation is Lo-Fi, and yet,
I think makes life better for me.
And it enhances my life experience,
and I thank you so much for that, Christopher.
I just wanted to bring this to everyone at the show,
and show 'em what we do.
My pleasure, thank you so much.
Thank you, Christopher, so much.
(upbeat contemporary music)